another thing in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood that got controversial was the
Bruce Lee scenes yeah yeah a lot of
people felt like you you made Bruce Lee
into an [ __ ] I can understand his
daughter having a problem with it it's
her [ __ ] father all right I get that
but anybody else go suck a dick
it's obvious Cliff tricked him they do a
two falls out of three contest so Cliff
loves [ __ ] like that you know uh uh and
he has a method and his method is to
give the guy the first fall okay do your
[ __ ] move dude let me see your move
all right he gives him no resistance
whatsoever but the guy does the move he
knocks him on his ass and there's
there's like four different ways Bruce
could have come at him the second time
that Cliff wouldn't would have had very
little defense against but most of the
time if a guy has a particular move and
it looks like the guy's a long head just
a big mouth who can't really defend
himself they do the first move again
well now Cliff knows what it is so he
prepares for it he pivots he catches him
he throws his ass into the car